i like welding man i do like it i used
to work at a
piping i used to work at a piping
company and my job was
washing off all the clevis hangers and
the
pipe fitter stuff and just organizing it
and
i had to paint and they had this kind of
rubber stuff
the sealant you have to put on things
and
every now and then uh this song by
sugar ray
would come on a radio
and uh
and sugar ray also sounds like a
nickname of like a
a gay man
but anyway every time this this band
sugar ray would come on the radio and
they had a song called i just want to
fly
you ever heard this song riley
i've not well you got to get out more
bubby and uh
it would come on and the welders would
stop their welding
and they'd make us subservience we was a
couple of us me and this
my tall friend billy he got bit by a
shark and he died actually
not at the same time he died later from
something else
aneurysm or pills but and god bless him
and i miss him he was tall and
he was an my friend billy was a
complete but
uh but he had he also was nice
you know he also was funny and we had a
nice time working together and we woke
up we worked this other
little fella named soldier
soldier this black gentleman and he was
he had on about 90 do-rags and
and he didn't do that's the irony
he would come to work and not do
like how you can have on 90 do rags and
you ain't
doing but we had a good time man
but anyway when the song would come on i
just want to fly
or cry maybe it could have been i just
want to cry
fly i just want to fly by sugar rays uh
that welders will make us dance you know
and they threaten us with the torches
and they make us dance but uh
very lord of the flies ass kind of
but we made the most of it and
and i really loved it man i loved going
over there i loved the sense of
community
you know i loved uh there was drug use
if you wanted it
and i didn't mind that um
so yeah i think getting a trade doing
some welding you get to wear neat hats
welders have neat hats
you know some cool little deals and
uh and their wives get mad at them a lot
i remember that a lot of the fellas
would talk about how their wives were
always mad at them
and we'd have good lunch to get you a
big po boy sandwich man
go over there by sweet gerald they had a
gay fellow over there
on the west bank of new orleans the
names a little sandwich place over there
named sweet gerald's and god damn it was
good the roast beef was wet bro
sweet gerald i'll say this he had a look
in his eye like he
he's sweeting the meat personally you
know what i'm saying and that was
that made you kind of cringe a little
you know when you swallowed but after
you
you know once you had a couple mouthfuls
of it you didn't you weren't complaining
anymore
but praise god brother thank you for
sending in that question
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one